so what we have here um cam ch 2019.65
so in our collection this is the 65th
thing we've taken in of 2019 we're not
that far into it um but if we open the
box what we have here is the very birth
of the sinclair spectrum
so this is the prototype of the sinclair
spectrum and actually quite a few people
bandy around the word prototype um and
it might be a pre-production prototype
but where it basically looks like the
machine but it's like an issue a rather
than issue one or whatever that kind of
stuff but this really really is as early
as it gets if we remove it from the bag
there
so if anybody knows the sinclair
spectrum
it kind of has a little bit of a feel of
it um when we was up in the the loft of
where this came from uh so it come from
a company called nine tiles when we
opened the box in the in the loft where
this thing was and we knew there was
some good going to be some good stuff
there because we knew the history of the
company uh that we were taking it from
um but uh yeah you open the box and you
see this thing and it's got all these
little signs that it's a spectrum
and it is a prototype and it was like
one of those indiana jones moments where
you find treasure right real treasure um
well this is to us anyway it is in two
parts so we have the keyboard and we
have the main board there and you've got
some little bits there that give you
clues the little speaker there is very
spectrum-like so that's the same one as
they use in the actual production model
uhf modulator over here voltage
regulator 7805 there on a big old
heatsink and then you've got some other
circuitry here to produce the negative
voltages that the ram uses ram chips
down here ula but with no actual writing
on it well apart from handwritten stuff
and then the z80 cpu which is the same
one
that they were putting into these x81 at
the time that's the zx81 so this is the
predecessor to the sinclair zx spectrum
this one personally for me has got lots
of fun memories this is a machine that
sort of cut my teeth on this x81 had a
grand total of one kilobyte of memory um
uh you could expand it you could have a
ram pack on the back but give it another
16k but it tended to wobble so every
time you started typing your code the
ram pack would move and you'd lose it
all anyway so that was pointless but the
sinclair spectrum had 16k of memory
built in as standard but then they
quickly released the 48k version as well
um so that was taken into an era now
where you can actually start to write
some good games um obviously this thing
was black and white
no sound nothing like that whereas the
spectrum had its beeps and what have you
and colour so
made it a much more salable machine when
it comes to the games so this is a
production version
of the sinclair spectrum so this is what
that
ended up being
so
no longer if we got the
full travel keys that was on the
prototype got this little
rubber they feel a little bit like
you're pressing dead flesh i don't know
who worked that out but
anyway but it was you know obviously all
into that little case and a great
engineering job to get all of that into
there there's a finished product
so
there you go
the prototype
and its uh
production release version if you look
underneath
you can see it's all been hand wire
wrapped the wire wrapping was a really
nice way of prototyping boards so you
didn't need to get pcbs made or anything
you'd have a little tool
and this blue wire here is a single core
wire with an outer sheath on it and that
would wrap around these long legs that
you can see and make a connection so you
take a pin here if you want to join that
pin to say over the processor you'd run
it along run it down over here use your
tool to make a wire out connection there
and away you go
so it's quite a rapid way of doing
things
and of course here you can see that
there's some other soldered wires on as
well these are on the power lines so
this is joining the power buses together
for each of the rows because you tend to
have a positive and a negative or zero
and five volt for each of these rows
here that would have taken quite a while
to do
so you know quite a painstaking
thing but obviously you know this was an
exciting time this is coming up with a
new product
um we do actually have as well
uh another
kind of it's pre this even yeah we
haven't uh
sort of done too much work with it yet
but it is as x81 that's been butchered
um to have a bigger rom capacity on it
the separate board so you can see they
were taking the x81 as the absolute
starting point um that was the product
that was out at the time um and thought
right how are we going to add more
memory to this how we can add all these
features so start with that and kind of
hack it um
get some more uh rom space on it uh so i
think there's about eight small rom
sockets on there
using smaller bombs and this one was
using
uh and so that's kind of the beginning
but then that didn't seem to go that far
i think by that time they realized now
we're gonna need to make a uh you know
an actual version ourselves um using uh
variable here so the keyboard is not
particularly like a spectrum somebody
pointed out actually it's interesting
that the z and the x things are missing
but i don't think that's anything other
than pure coincidence oh because it's a
zx zx spectrum yeah um they were never
on there we've never seen them um i
can't imagine anybody nicking them to
stick on their fridge um so
i i think that's just because they've
come off it's unfortunate
but obviously not very spectrum-like
spectrum had its own
rubber keyboard so this uses
rs
key switches so this is a standard um
keyboard bezel that you could buy a
little metal frame there and you could
just push these rs keys which is into
them rs was a company called radio
spares which still are and they sell
everything on that score so they've
obviously gone out and bought some rs
key switches so they've wired this up
in a matrix so you can see there's kind
of rows and columns that go across just
as on a normal spectrum membrane and
then they've got this really heavy duty
again rs connector there so a db25
connector there that connects it onto
the the main board
so those two connected together gives
you
your keyboard
and the spectrum itself
um so yeah this is
really quite
exciting i mean you don't get this kind
of thing come up very often obviously
from my experience when you when you're
prototyping something
you get this far you basically prove
it's okay they're probably not the most
reliable thing in the world you've got
connections they're a little bit iffy
maybe so you can do some tests and it's
yes we know this is going to work and
then you move on to a pcb as soon as you
can but what usually happens is as soon
as you get the pcbs in you're all
excited right let's make one of these up
and you just rip all the components off
your prototype and prototypes end up in
a draw and you keep rubbing it for bits
or whatever as you need them so it's not
very often that something like this
comes along in its entirety complete you
know that's very very uncommon so we're
really really lucky well where did you
say you found it again um so this was
donated to us we got contact from a lady
called kate grant um so her and her
husband had a company called ninetales
um and they had various old bits of junk
that we might be interested in um they
had a pdp 11 a really big pdp 11 35
system um i think 1170 as well various
other things um and this was kind of a
footnote to that you know oh and there
might be a prototype of things like the
spectrum and
whatever so
okay vaguely interested you know um so
uh yeah that was kind of more of a
footnote to the the other things but
that happened so many times people
offered to donate things to us um
and then you know we're really excited
about the thing that they were
less excited about um
so it happens a lot and this is a great
example of it this is the most extreme
example we've come across um have you
fired it up not yet no is there a plan
i think we're getting some grief online
because we haven't done it yet um but um
unfortunately day-to-day business gets
in the way yes we definitely are going
to but also you've got to take a lot of
precautions over something like that
surely yeah yeah definitely i mean this
is a you know there isn't another one
we're not going to do this thing any
damage i mean you might look at this and
go hang on this is a little little bit
for the cameras well no i wouldn't say
we haven't done that before have we i
mean so there's a couple of things so um
the museum has now become museums
credited um that's a really big deal to
us um that means that we apply
procedures and policies to the way that
we do we the way that we run the museum
um but also the way that we do
preservation and it proves that we're
taking it seriously um
secondly regardless of all that
this is special you know until we've
dumped the roms which we are going to do
as soon as we can for anybody that's
wondering why we don't just stick it in
the eprom reader now um which we were
gonna do on day one but these are
actually two five six four roms is it
two five six four or is it yeah there
are two five six fours so i was just
expecting these to be two seven series a
problems as many machines would use but
two five series are a different pin out
um and they need to be treated slightly
differently so our reader by default
won't read them so we need to make a
little adapter that is going to take
these convert them into the same pin out
as a two seven series and then we'll
read them so that's what's getting in
the way really um and it's just again
one of those little things that needs to
be done that other things get in the way
of um but so so there's that and
obviously you don't want to go and do
something to this that's going to damage
the data on those roms so we're being
ultra careful there
also some of these components are static
sensitive so we do have the static mat
here and we're earth and i'm wearing
these gloves and the gloves are again
not necessarily for the static but
they're about getting oil and grease and
things off your hands on these things
you know we are
really seriously taking
uh taking all this so it's you know it's
about preserving these and treating them
in the best way we possibly can but yes
we're gonna try and fire up as soon as
what we're going to do is we'll take all
the components out um we'll power it up
make sure we've got the right voltages
so we have
a little um negative voltage converter
there for the ram make sure that's
sticking out the right voltage uh make
sure the five is being dropped down
properly it'll be terrible if we just
plugged it into an adapter and the the
nine volt went straight through the the
regulator or something like that we're
not gonna do that so we'll take check it
all out first put the chips back in
and then see where we go from there um
and as soon as we do we'll let people
know obviously um there's enough people
emailing and saying well you put out a
video about it but you haven't told us
anything else yeah it doesn't work
so the only scientist we just haven't
quite got around to it but it's not for
the want of our own kind of let's get to
it there's other day-to-day things we
have to do
now i've got the token so i can load a
value in add the value for merger into
it and store it back and hand the token
and now i've got the token again i can
load something into
into my register add something onto it
throw it back and pass the token on and
i've got it so i can load the value in
add the value for my register store it
back